ότι ο νίκος λοιζείς κάπου δεσχολιάζει τόσο πολύ τοσο έντονα τά της γυνεται στην αστυνμία
ίσιοπας και δέρχεσαι τα πάντα ή λες τα πράγματα με το νόμαντους τον αλλάζει συνεχός
αρχηγούς υπαρχηγούς αλλάζεις απλά που κάμισου επεί οποία στυνομική υπάρχου σήμερα πάρχει επάγγελμα που δεν
εκεί η ευταρμένος μας αρμόζει αυτή αστυνομία μετέτρεψανται να αστυνομία και θα το πω γιατί
ίσουν τοσον έντονοςσ με τον στένιο πόμαθεβο τον προστάτευσα δύο φορες βγήκαν προστά που κανένας
άλλος γα ν εβγαινε γιατί το οργανωμένο έγκλημα εναι έναν οι δύο βήματα ποιο μπροστά
από την αστυμοτο οργανομένο κλημα εξυγχρονί στη κ επίες άλλες μορφές εμείς επαραμείναμε μας άρπαξα
συναδέλφισα οργανωμένε της μιας μάδαμα στην άρπαξαν όπως ήταν απιλές δέκτηκες αζείχνει ότι παίρνου μετες
μποείνες με στην αστυνομία αφήστε να προαχθούν οι καλύτεροι και αφήστετα ρουσφέθκε ναι εκαρος για
τα κόματα τώρα να εκατόντο μεστην αστυνομίατι επικράτησε στην αστυνομία τους τελευταίους τέςυ τερις μήνες
που αλλά ξενηγεσία εγώ θα το πω δεν έχω εκανε ένα θέμα να μετοεπικρατεί θεωρίς
ότι πρέα νιώθει ασφαλες ο κύπριος πολίτης με την αστυνομία που έχ σήμερα τός ο
τόπος φήλες και φέλι άλλοναντεέναλλά εο σήμερα μαζί σας κάτισα σας τυνομίας θα δούμε σήμερα
αρκετά τα θέματα των τελευταίον ευδομάδω αλλά θα θέλαμε να κάνομε μια δεύτερη ανάγνωση μαζί
μας ο πρόεδρος της όδητας ο κύριος νίκος λοιζήτης ένα τομο το οποίο σχολιάζει σχεδόν
καθημερινάτα όσα γινώνταις στα της αστυνομίας είπαμε να το φιλοξινήσουμε στο πότικας για να κια
να δούμε καλύτερα είσωςκάποια θέματα να τα αναπτύξουμε κάπως και ελοιζίδε ευχαριστώ πολύ για τι
είναιαποδοχεί της πρόσκλησης ώστε να συζητήσουμε